[Music]
it's time for et's social study your
quick look at what the Stars have been
posting online Ellen DeGeneres isn't
waiting any longer she took to Twitter
to hilariously announce she wants to
join
fifth harmony after Camilla Kibeho exit
from the group hosting this amazing pic
of herself photoshopped into a group
shot of the girls wearing a matching red
jumpsuit writing looks like it's just us
now the girls seem to be loving the idea
that jokingly responded with you and
your tracksuit are late for rehearsals
where you at girl even Camilla got in on
the action
tweeting man replaced so soon but
admitted Ellen had always been a better
dancer speaking of dancers Dancing with
the Stars champ Lorri Hernandez got a
surprise while on tour with the show her
fellow Olympian Simone biles Simone
posted some adorable pics of the two
along with her cast mates another
dancing champ bindi Irwin shared this
adorable video to Instagram of her
boyfriend Chandler Powell trying his
first lychee while the two enjoyed a
dinner picnic together in Australia Big
Five baby's fake a55 meanwhile Nicole
Richie and Kate Hudson are keeping their
New Year's resolution of getting their
fitness back on track even if they are a
little behind
Kate shared a pic of her and her gal
pals to the gram after a hike in LA
joking in the caption
we had no fun at all hashtag ten days of
getting back on track
new year new bow demi lovato may have
opened her heart to a new man by the
looks of this pic MMA fighter gear may
Bamba vasconcelos posted of himself and
the confidence singer cuddled up
together Marc Anthony's ex Shannon de
Lima is starting off 2017 on a happy
note the model shared this gorgeous shot
of herself on her 28th birthday rocking
a white bikini in the ocean captioning
the pic I'm starting off the new year on
a really happy note and with a big
desire to enjoy it and make the best out
of it
[Music]